i don't know anything about the internal
politics or the mechanisms obviously
section 230 uh creates a major obstacle
to
using the courts as they would obviously
be rightly used in this case
um you know it's effectively a loophole
that has to be fixed in our legal
structure because uh you know alex brown
can libel using the megaphone of
wikipedia
and his ability to shut down anybody
else's
protest of his misinformation
so i haven't known what to do my hope is
that actually
jimmy wales will
look at this podcast
and he will think very carefully about
the fact that he has
here jimmy let me talk to you directly
actually if you're watching this
i want to tell you something uh about my
grandfather
um
my grandfather was
uh he was a wonderful guy his name was
harry rubin and he
held a lifelong conviction that if
people could manage to see past their
mundane day-to-day interest that we
would be capable of
great things and that although the
market created wonderful things it was
not the only mechanism for the
production of of tremendous value
and shortly before he died
i showed him wikipedia
right i opened up my laptop and i said i
want to show you something harry
take a look at this
you were right
this is the greatest encyclopedia in the
history of the world by orders of
magnitude and it was not generated by
the profit motive this was crowdsourced
it ain't perfect but wow is it better
than the next nearest competitor by an
incredible degree so i showed him that i
was very
pleased to to let him know before he
died
that um that that instinct of his was
borne out by something as marvelous as
wikipedia for wikipedia now to be guilty
of outright libeling people who dared
simply to talk to the public about what
was in their own interests in the
instance of a frightening emerging
pandemic is appalling
there is no way that you should be
allowing wikipedia to be used in that
way even if we were wrong just simply
report the facts accurately
libeling us is unacceptable and the fact
that it may be protected by section 230
is irrelevant right this is the library
of alexandria and if it can't be fixed
then it has to be replaced because at
the moment what it's doing is it's
sitting in the niche
of the great global democratizing
encyclopedia and it is preventing us
from putting together something else
that will do the job if wikipedia
refuses to so
look it's lying in the sand time either
fix the damn thing so it is not possible
to destroy somebody if you're uh you
know a freelance
uh editor who decides they have a
perspective that they want to turn into
a fact right either fix the damn thing
or get the hell out of the way because
we need something that does the job of
wikipedia and the fact that
founders like larry sanger believe that
it can't be fixed well that's a
challenge to you it is time it is time
to fix this mechanism and
you know maybe wikipedia 2.0 is the
answer
[Music]